Mr Speaker I've just returned from the
G7 Summit in Japan where I was humbled
to be the first prime minister of the
United Kingdom to visit Hiroshima on
behalf of this house and the British
people I recorded our great sorrow at
the destruction and human suffering that
occurred there and our fervent resolve
that it should never again be necessary
to use nuclear weapons
as I report to the house on the G7
Summit I want to address a head-on a
mistaken view that is heard too often
the idea that Britain is somehow in
Retreat on the world stage or that our
influence is in Decline I reject that
utterly
what we've seen in recent months is this
conservative government delivering the
priorities of the British people and
bringing our Global influence to bear
and some of the world's biggest
challenges
nowhere is that clearer than Ukraine it
was a pleasure and privilege to welcome
my friend president zielinski back to
the UK last week
his attendance at the G7 Summit was a
historic moment
when Putin launched his War he gambled
that our resolve would falter that he
was wrong then and he is wrong now
Russia's military is failing on the
battlefield their economy is failing at
home as we tighten the Stranglehold of
sanctions
and the image of the G7 leaders standing
shoulder to shoulder with president
zielinski and Hiroshima sent a powerful
message to the world we will stand with
Ukraine for as long as it takes
of course we've seen a huge Collective
effort across our allies not least the
United States
but I'm incredibly proud of our role at
the Forefront of international support
for Ukraine the first country in the
world
to train Ukrainian troops first in
Europe to provide lethal weapons first
to commit tanks and just this month
first to provide long-range weapons
and we've now at the Forefront of a
coalition to train and equip the
Ukrainian Air Force we gave 2.3 billion
pounds of military aid last year second
only to the United States and will match
or exceed that this year
Putin should know that we are not going
anywhere
and we know that Ukraine will not only
win the war but can and will win a just
and Lasting peace
based on respect for international law
the principles of the UN Charter and
territorial integrity and sovereignty
and Mr Speaker we bring that same
resolve to the biggest challenge to the
long-term security and prosperity of our
age China
as the G7 showed the UK's response is
completely aligned with our allies we
are working with others to strengthen
our defense ties across the indo-pacific
diversify our supply chains in areas
like critical minerals and
semiconductors and prevent China using
economic coercion to interfere with the
sovereignty of others
concrete actions not rhetoric
but our Economic Security is not just
about managing the risks of China Mr
Speaker we're taking advantage of our
post-brexit freedoms with a hugely
ambitious trade policy we've concluded
negotiations on the cptpp a trade deal
with the world's fastest growing region
we've signed critical mineral
Partnerships with Canada and Australia a
semiconductor partnership with Japan
The Windsor framework secures the free
flow of trade within our UK internal
market and on Friday we announced almost
18 billion pounds of new investment into
the UK from Japanese businesses
that's a huge vote of confidence in the
United Kingdom
creating significant numbers of good
well-paid jobs and helping grow the
economy
and Mr Speaker we're acting globally to
tackle illegal migration it is the
British government who will determine
who comes to Britain we must stop the
boats and break the business model of
the criminal gangs
to do that we're deepening International
cooperation to tackle illegal migration
through new deals with Albania France
and just at last week's Council of
Europe starting with the EU border force
2. and at this weekend Summit we've
secured agreement that we will increase
G7 cooperation to
so Mr Speaker our foreign policy is
clearly delivering for the British
people by strengthening our
relationships with old friends and new
from the indo-pacific to Washington to
Europe we're delivering a diplomatic
dividend for the UK and that's not all
we've announced billions more for our
defense the largest contributor in
Europe to Nato we signed a historic
agreement to design and build the Orca
submarine giving the UK Australia and
the U.S interoperable submarine fleets
in the Atlantic and the Pacific we've
launched a new program to build the
fighter jets of the future with Italy
and Japan
announced that in 2025 the carrier
strike group will return to the
indo-pacific once more and in Sudan the
British military completed the largest
evacuation of any country
and if anyone thinks the UK is no longer
able to wield hard power in defense of
our values just ask the Ukrainian
soldiers driving British tanks or firing
our long-range missiles
all that Mr Speaker is how we will
prosper at home and defend our values
abroad that's how our foreign policy is
delivering for the British people and
that's why on the world stage Britain is
forging ahead confident proud and free
and I commend this statement